In this recession, don't stop spending.
Haggle your way to better prices.
A Consumer Reports poll says that 81 percent of consumers...
...haggle their way to cheaper clothes.
Retailers want to sell their inventory and will give discount on the spot.
And yes, even you can do it.
First, look them in the eye.
If you find the perfect jeans, find the best price then bargain.
Tell them you will walk if they don't give you a better price.
Buy in bulk, save money.
Buying shoes, slacks and a sweater?
Tell them you want a discount.
Because remember, salespeople work on commission.
Be friendly.
Salespeople will be more likely to give you a discount, tell you about sales...
...and might even let you use their employee discount.
Don't pay full price, all you got to do is ask.